like you bring up the concept of faith I
know that you've found uh God Jesus
while you were in the can right I
believe you also did the same when you
are you uh
before I went to pray you are but so
what role has Faith played in your life
at this point because you see in America
the decline in family decline in
religion decline in the community
service
um and you know we see that the pat says
this all the time that churches should
be packed these days you know churches
should uh revive America's greatness
what role has religion played in your
guys life and and what are people
lacking as they're clinging to politics
and political ideology and wokeness as
some may regard uh rather than faith in
God
man there you go Mike I just believe
that um I'm praise being all lies
believe God should be
your personal
entity I don't believe God should be you
know that's my opinion you you shove
your relationship with God because when
you when is your turn to go in front of
God you're going to be alone
Judgment Day your homeboy is not gonna
be inside your mother your father you'll
be alone you know that's what they say
so you have to have your own personal
relationship with God in any way you
believe it's possible that's better and
help you reach your Highest Potential
sometimes um
they can't do it from a
some people can't deal with religion
from a perspective of this is the way it
is from the Bible from the book and I
don't know everyone don't get into it
from that perspective they want their
own personal relationship with Allah
you're saying more spiritual than more
structured religion yes but they the
structure is good as well some people
some of us need the structure that's why
we have destruction the Quran in the
Bible because some people feed on that
alone that's their objective and um I
just think they all have their purpose
all religion has the purpose and all the
religion from my experience now came
from the
what do you call those people before
before the Egyptian Sumerians it's the
same the same religion they have at the
same religion in the Bible some parts of
the Quran Moses is a different name it's
Gilgamesh you know so all religion even
though I saw this once before if I could
be permitted to say I was in Egypt and
I'm a Muslim and I saw on the the
carvings they had statues doing the
Muslim
um prayer the way we pray you know and I
said wow this had this had to influence
Islam a lot you know the statue that's
that's hundreds of you know like
thousands of years old
so we don't know anything about this
world we just know what we were taught
or told we have no ideology who we are
where we came from who our ancestors
really were
you know
how about you Mike I couldn't have said
it better but you know personal
relationship that's what it's all about
I mean you you got to have a you know
moral Foundation you got to have
something and and uh to me it's all
about my personal relationship with God
now obviously you know I go out and
speak and share it but I feel I'm
obligated to do that but uh it's it's
like you said you're going to stand in
front of God alone you and him nobody
else you know and so often you know you
get on social media and Patrick you know
there's people who say this and I had so
many crazy people online and I don't
respond to any of that because
you do care about what people say don't
get me wrong but at the end of the day
you know it's you and God alone and you
got to get it straight with him and I'm
I'm pretty heavy on donations too stuff
I love you know if that helps then help
me or everybody this is what I realized
in my life even myself
even when I give my tips always give
tips out
it's a good thing but subconsciously I'm
trying to buy my way to heaven you know
you're not a theater maybe buying our
way to heaven you need this you need
okay
in the Jewish religion that's called
sadaka you know really
there we go Tupac once said only God
could judge me yeah good to see a Muslim
a Catholic I'm not sure and a Jewish
guy but listen check this out imagine we
were in no religion no we will be yeah
we'll be brothers
if we didn't have no religions and we
had four guys together we'll be brothers
right we all have the same belief we
don't believe in God earth religion you
know we brother there's always religion
because religion is just an action
something that's um
repetition what we do we wake up every
day our lifestyles and religion whatever
we do is the concept of religion
repetition
belief so if you like this clip and you
want to watch another one click right
here and if you want to watch the entire
podcast click right here
[Music]